Because across the board, we realized that bi-specifics are very disparate across myeloma.
We are very spoiled academic sites, but community sites really need to get access to these.
And I think it's our job to partner with them.
So here's a couple examples to kind of show partnerships throughout history here.
So we have Jack and Colby.
I know this is controversial.
My husband said I should have put a Bulls team together from the 90s.
We have, you know, for those of us that are millennials, we really gravitate to, I think, Rachel and Monica.
And then I got to say, yeah, for the boomers, but also for myself, I am a huge Al Pacino fan.
So you have Robert De Niro and Al Pacino, who are actually real life friends.
Okay, so just going through, the point of this slide is to show all the different nuances between the four FDA-approved myeloma bi-specifics
and how there's all these different nuances between step-up dosing, the frequency of the dosing,
and even with intelcodamab, it originally came out with two different dose strategies for ramp-up.
And that ramp-up then went to every week or every two weeks.
So there's a lot of challenges within step-up dosing.
Just within the academic center and then trying to figure out, well, how are we going to now navigate our community practice positions
to learn how to do this along with every other thing that they're expected to navigate?
So we're focused on myeloma.
And I think it's our job to really figure out a blueprint within the resources that exist in the community
that it can easily transition from us as the expert to them.
So I'll go through kind of a plan A versus a plan B.
Okay.
So the limitation of community practice is probably the number one issue.
Like it was mentioned previously from some of my colleagues here,
a lot of them don't even have access to a hospital to admit patients to.
There's also a lot of fear of CRS and ICANNs.
The REMS program itself brings a lot of that on.
And I think one of our jobs is education.
The travel distance to get to us, it's going to be far easier for patients to be able to get this in their own backyard.
Caregiver support, that's going to remain a barrier.
It's going to be a big issue regardless of where patients are getting this.
Education of the patients, the clinical team.
So I do a lot of going into our regional community practice sites.
And there's a lot of people that need to be involved in the clinical team education.
After our support is going to be a huge issue too in the community.
So not all of us have access to a third-party monitoring system.
So when we developed our outpatient program, we actually opted to not use one.
We did that on purpose because we want to think about next steps of how are we going to transition this from our center to any center.
So we have to work with our pharmaceutical colleagues.
That would be those in the back of the room here.
Consortiums, working groups.
We have to develop and publish real-world data on how to manage this from step-up or the plan B, which would be taking patients,
we do the step-up at the academic site, and then they return home.
I think plan A is better.
We'll go over plan A and B next.
We need to really partner and be more accessible to our community partners.
By partnering with them, it doesn't mean that they're going to sit there and call you at 2 in the morning and use you as the after-hours service.
That's not the point.
The point is to make yourself available for a text message here or there and be able to help guide them.
Once they get through the first couple,
I'm very surprised at how well they've adapted to becoming comfortable doing this.
So plan A is going to be doing this whole thing outpatient and being able to have the community docs work within their resources.
So the prior presentations here talking about using dexamethasone or using tocilizumab.
So when you look at dexamethasone, you'll get what's been published out there.
Those rates basically cut the CRS rate.
When you look at tocilizumab, though, it's driving most of the rates below 10%.
And what we are seeing is almost entirely grade one that can be safely managed all outpatient.
So I really think it should be kind of the best of both worlds.
I do think the prophylactic TOSI is probably the best option.
Having it on NCCN should not be a huge barrier.
As far as people mentioning the cost of acquisition of the product, there's a lot of biosimilars that are coming.
There's a lot more competition.
There's allowing price reductions in tocilizumab.
It should not be an insurance reimbursement issue, which I think is what we were originally worried about.
Being able to have what we call pocket docs so that the patients are instructed on what to do if they were to get a low-grade fever.
So there's a lot of pros to doing a plan A of having the whole thing outpatient.
The patients are able to remain close to home.
We're able to start having a plan in place to work within any community.
We're able to have a community practice to use the resources that they have and be able to not rely on the use of a hospital system.
So not needing the use of emergency rooms except in very rare events, not needing to have hospitalized patients.
I think that that is our main goal is be able to get this to a point where we're really having pretty close to zero reason to be using emergency rooms and hospitals with this step-up.
The people that are looking at all the behind-the-scenes and thinking of these rare one-in-a-million scenarios, and that's the big stopgap.
Reliance on an emergency room and the rare refractory CRS or ICAMs.
Now, plan B.
This is what a lot of us actually started doing in the real world is plan B.
They partner with us.
We bring them to us.
We step them up.
We get them through the acute tox phase.
And then, ideally, they react.
We return home.
How often this actually happens in the real world, not as often as we'd like it to happen.
So, the REMS program, I think, has been very misleading with about the timing and severity of CRS and ICAMs.
When you get in there and you do your training for REMS and you're having a new center look at all this, that is where the administrative leads get concerned.
They start to see all this, well, if we see a grade three, you're recommending considering placing them in an ICU.
We don't even have hospital admission privileges.
So, how are we going to mitigate this and deal with all these safety issues?
So, the pros of this, it does work within most existing infrastructure resources.
You send your patient up two, three hours away.
They do the step-up dosing.
The cons, there's a lot of fear amongst the community practitioners that they're never going to see their patient again.
Their patient's going to go.
They're never going to come home.
Does that happen in reality?
In some circumstances, yes.
But I think as an academic physician, we want our patients to return home.
We want them to be able to be with their referring doctor.
I think we're reinforcing this fear about CRS and ICAMs.
I think it's being overblown quite a bit.
And so, this plan of hybrid model is kind of reinforcing that.
I don't think we're going to get beyond and get to plan A.
And then you need to have this really good communication for smooth transitions between sites.
Thank you.
All right.